T
HAVE PUT THE VIOLENT CRIMINALS
ABOVE VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
JUST ASK MY NEXT GUEST, DESIREE
ANDRE, A LEADER IN THE RECALL
GASCON MOVEMENT.
HER SON WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED
BACK IN 2018.
HE WAS REPEATEDLY STABBED,
BEATEN, AND THEN HE WAS THROWN
OFF A CLIFF, HIS BODY WAS FOUND
TWO DAYS LATER.
AND NOW, THANKS TO GASCON'S
"REFORMED POSTCODE, NONE OF HIS
KILLERS WILL ACTUALLY FACE LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE.
DESIREE JOINS ME NOW.
DESIREE, I KNOW PEOPLE SAY I'M
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT HELPS BUT
IT'S DESPERATELY SAD AND
INFURIATING STORY AND AS A
MOTHER, MY HEART DOES BREAK FOR
YOU.
I'M SO SORRY.
BUT YOUR STORY COULD PERHAPS
MAKE A DIFFERENCE HERE.
TELL US WHAT YOU ARE FEELING
GIVEN WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
HAPPENING DAY IN AND DAY OUT AT
THE HANDS OF GEORGE GASCON.
>> AND FEELING -- FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU, LAURA, FOR HAVING ME.
I'M FEELING LET DOWN BY THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
MY SON WAS TRULY BEATEN AND
TORTURED TO DEATH BACK IN
MAY 2018 AND THE FIVE KILLERS
INVOLVED IN HIS MURDER ARE NO
LONGER COME AS YOU MENTIONED,
ARE NO LONGER FACING LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE OR THE DEATH
PENALTY.
THESE GENTLEMEN ARE NOW FACING
25 YEARS AND ONLY HAVING TO DO
80% OF THAT TIME, WHICH IS 20
YEARS.
THAT IS NOT ENOUGH.
MY SON HAS A SENTENCE, HIS
SENTENCE WAS DEATH.
I WILL NEVER SEE MY SON AGAIN.
HOW ARE THEY -- HOW IS IT EVEN
THE THOUGHT THAT THEY WILL BE
OUT IN TIME TO CREATE FAMILIES
OF THEIR OWN AND DO EVERYTHING
THAT MY SON WAS CHEATED FROM?
SO I FEEL LET DOWN BY GEORGE
GASCON, I FEEL IT'S PERSONAL
NOW, I FEEL THAT HIM NEGLECTING
THE VICTIMS IS PERSONAL, AND FOR
HIM NOT TO REACH OUT FOR ME IS
PERSONAL.
I THINK IS A DANGER TO
L.A. COUNTY, POINT BLANK.
>> Laura: WHAT WAS THE
REACTION OF YOUR SON'S MURDERERS
WHEN THEY FOUND OUT THAT THEY'D
BE GETTING OUT IN 20 YEARS?
>> IT WAS SICKENING, ACTUALLY.
MY DAUGHTER AND I SAT IN COURT.
ONE OF THEM GAVE A FIST BUMP TO
HIS ATTORNEY AND HIS ATTORNEY
LOOKED AT HIM LIKE "GOOD JOB"
AND WAS SMILING FROM EAR TO EAR
AND IT WAS DONE ALL IN FRONT OF
ME, WHICH WAS A SLAP IN THE
FACE.
IT JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU WHERE
WE ARE AT.
CRIMINALS ARE NOW CONSIDERED
VICTIMS.
WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
IT'S THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
I FEEL THAT THEY ARE GETTING
MORE JUSTICE THAN WE THE VICTIMS
ARE AND IT'S NOT RIGHT AT ALL.
>> Laura: I WANT TO SHOW SOME
GOOD NEWS HERE, DESIREE, WHICH
IS THE CURRENT POLLING ABOUT
THIS GEORGE SOROS-SUPPORTED
D.A., MR. GASCON.
25% APPROVAL RATING, A 40.8%
DISAPPROVAL RATING AND 61% SAY
THEY'LL VOTE FOR AN UNNAMED
ALTERNATIVE CANDIDATE.
YOUR MESSAGE TO DEMOCRAT WOMEN
IN THIS STATE WHO JUST CAN'T
FEEL LIKE THEY CAN VOTE TO VOTE
AGAINST A DEMOCRAT THAT'S AN
OFFICE LIKE GEORGE GASCON
BECAUSE YOU NEED ABOUT, YOU
KNOW -- YOU NEED 580,000
SIGNATURES BY OCTOBER 27TH TO
GET THIS RECALL IN ORDER, SO
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM
TONIGHT?
>> I'M A DEMOCRAT.
WE NEED TO ALL WAKE UP.
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL STANCE,
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL EFFORT,
THIS IS ABOUT A FIGHT FOR WHAT'S
RIGHT AND WHAT'S WRONG.
WE NEED TO WAKE UP.
WE NEED TO COMMIT -- GET
TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY, AS
ANGELENOS, AND GET THIS MAN OUT
OF OFFICE.
I'M TELLING YOU ALL, YOU DO NOT
WANT TO BE IN MY PLACE, YOU DO
NOT EVER WANT TO LOSE YOUR SON.
YOU DO NOT EVER WANT TO BE A
PART OF THIS RIGHT HERE.
YOU DO NOT WANT TO BE A PART OF
THIS VIOLENCE, YOU DO NOT WANT
TO BE ABOUT THIS DESTROYED
TERMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT'S JUST GONE WRONG, SO PLEASE,
EVERYBODY WAKE UP.
THESE POLES MEAN NOTHING WITHOUT
THESE SIGNATURES, WE NEED
SIGNATURES.
PLEASE GO TO -- DOWNLOAD THE
PETITION, SIGN, WE NEED HIM OUT.
THIS IS NOW DOWN TO CRUNCH TIME
AND I JUST DO NOT WANT HIM TO
STAY IN OFFICE, HE IS A DANGER,
LIKE I SAID.
I AM SCARED, I AM SCARED FOR OUR
SAFETY.
PLEASE, I AM BEGGING ALL OF YOU
TO PLEASE TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
>> Laura: DESIREE, I DON'T
RECOGNIZE L.A.
I FIRST CAME HERE IN 1984, I
THOUGHT I HAD DIED AND GONE TO
HEAVEN, IT WAS THE MOST CREDIBLE
PLACE.
WATCHING YOUR PAIN, THE PAIN OF
SO MANY PARENTS, EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING HERE, IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
IT'S COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
I WILL POST THE LINK TO THE
WEBSITE SO WE CAN GET MORE
SIGNATURES.
WE WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH YOU
OBVIOUSLY BEFORE THE OCTOBER
DEADLINE, BUT THIS CANNOT BE FOR
NAUGHT.
DESIREE, THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THE STORY, I KNOW IT IS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT FOR YOU AND
WE REALL